this video is sponsored by Skillshare
the first 1000 people to join with the
link in the description get two free
months to watch thousands of high
quality classes for most of the world
the term public housing conjures a clear
mental picture at best it means
uninspired rows of the same drab
concrete boxes the soviet-era copy and
pasted urban hell that's or the poor
run-down crime-infested bad neighborhood
the place those with no other options
and up for most of the world and then
there's Singapore their public housing
looks like this this and this because
80% of the population lives in one of
its 1 million public apartments they
carry no social stigma and are enjoyed
by the rich and poor alike the small
island city-state has adopted such a
unique set of policies that the usual
measures fail to accurately capture just
how far ahead it is the ratio of median
house price to income for example is the
most common simple way of comparing
affordability it reveals how many years
the average person would need to work to
afford the average house in their area
unfortunately it's based only on
privately sold properties a reasonable
standard for most countries but
meaningless in Singapore
it also neglects factors like the
availability of loans government
subsidies and national savings funds all
of which help make public housing the
obvious choice for most all Singaporeans
another misleading statistic is the
homeownership rate which would seem to
make it only one of many countries where
ownership is near-universal confusingly
this number is calculated based not on
the number of adults who own a home but
rather the share of homes occupied by
their owner in other words a
hypothetical city where prices have
risen to such completely unaffordable
levels that all adult children are
forced to live with their parents would
technically have a 100% homeownership
rate seeing as every home would still be
occupied by its legal owner
so while Singapore does have a 90
percent homeownership rate it's true
accomplishment is 90 percent flat
neighborhood and estate
satisfaction while at the same time
remaining affordable for everyone
somehow its leaders seem to have solved
the problem of housing that it can be
affordable high quality or plentiful but
not all three the question then is can
these policies be exported elsewhere
public housing was first introduced on
the island with the creation of the
Singapore Improvement Trust under
British rule in 1927 the si T was an
attempt to solve the city's growing
problem of overcrowding the poor at the
time mainly lived in unsanitary slums
and high-density shop houses where they
readily spread disease the situation was
made even worse by Japan's World War two
invasion and occupation during which
thousands of homes were destroyed and
thousands more were haphazardly
constructed when Singapore finally
gained self-governance in 1959 just 9
percent lived in public apartments while
the population had grown rapidly from
250,000 in 1907 to 567 thousand in 1931
and nearly a million by 1947 housing had
lagged behind an already dense nine
point seven people per building had
become 18 in that same period by almost
every measure the SI T had failed major
changes were needed and fast just weeks
after assuming power the newly formed
People's Action Party began replacing it
with the current Housing and Development
Board while the new department clearly
had its work cut out for it
in hindsight this regulatory blank slate
was probably its biggest strength
allowing it to envision utopia
unhindered by the past it was also
highly motivated Lee Kuan Yew the
nation's first Prime Minister considered
the founder of Singapore wrote that home
ownership was the key to giving its
population of immigrants a stake in the
country because of this the HDB was
given an extraordinary degree of freedom
including a personal guarantee that
money would not be a problem it was
exempted from building ordinance laws
and mostly allowed to operate without
approval from other department
immediately it got to work the first
priority was existential solving the
acute housing shortage by building as
much and as fast as possible early flats
were designed as emergency single room
units with the most bare-bones of
amenities at the same time using its
almost infinitely long leash it began
aggressively acquiring land in 1961 a
massive fire broke out in a squatter
settlement prompting the government to
pass the fire site provision which
allowed it to acquire any land occupied
by squatters which was cleared by fire
or natural disaster the fire and the
government success in relocating the
victims was held up as proof of its
efficacy paving the way for future
legislation three years later another
law was amended which enabled the state
to reclaim land without needing to
compensate the affected seafront land
owners then in 1966 the land acquisition
act took this trend to the extreme
authorizing the acquisition of land by
quote any person corporation or
statutory board for any work or an
undertaking which in the opinion of the
minister is a poet benefit or public
utility or in the public interest for
any residential commercial or industrial
purpose landowners could not object and
compensation was then provided at below
market prices when it ran out of land to
take the state began reclaiming the sea
which makes up about one-fifth of the
country today including the famous
Marina Bay from 1960 to 2005 the percent
of government owned land grew from 44 to
90 percent and by the mid-1960s hundreds
of thousands had moved into government
housing under the leadership of the
prolific Lim Kim San naturally there
were a few snags along the transition
from slums to high-rises many residents
had no idea how to budget for rent or
electricity while others simply found
life that high up unnatural over
although the process was remarkably
smooth and when Lim died in 2006 he was
remembered as the mastermind behind
Singapore's residential revolution in
1964 the HDB introduced the home
ownership scheme which today attracts
international attention and
as of 2020 there are over 1 million
public flats mostly situated in 24 new
towns around the island
each is designed to self contain around
one to two hundred thousand people with
their own schools grocery stores
hospitals gyms and malls most residents
only need to leave for work which is
made easy by the attached MRT train
stations and although their coverage is
extensive areas without them are
connected by smaller light rail stations
while this is functionally similar to
estates in Hong Kong where rows of
high-rise apartments surround a common
area mall and train station there's one
critical difference instead of walling
in residence and preventing air
circulation new towns in Singapore are
arranged in a somewhat checkerboard
manner with alternating tall and short
buildings it's not hard to guess in
which a state residents feel happier are
less likely to vandalize and are prouder
of their communities another important
feature of its apartment buildings are
known as void decks one floor usually
the first is reserved as a communal
space for Malay weddings Chinese funeral
wakes polling stations and other events
the unit's themselves come in many
shapes and sizes from one to five room
flats and everything in between
there are even executive condos designed
built and priced by private developers
but subsidized by the government at
below market prices subject to the HDB's
restrictions the best apartments are
nice enough to evade the usual public
housing connotation while the low end is
made affordable by a variety of
government programs first and most
importantly Singaporeans have no choice
but to save their money all workers
under 55 are required by law to
contribute 20% of their wages and their
employers another 17% to a social
savings fund that can be withdrawn from
only for a few specific reasons of which
buying a house is the most common in
this way and countless others Singapore
has completely removed housing from the
free market prices are set based on
one's ability to pay individuals can't
own more than one public flat at a time
and although foreigners are not banned
from buying they're required to pay
significant stamp duties the nature of
housing is thus a place to live
not an investment which is not to say
homes aren't assets they do serve that
role just secondarily owners of new
subsidized flats are allowed to sell
them at market rates after five years of
occupancy usually to buyers who don't
want to wait the three to four years for
new projects to be completed likewise
the elderly are encouraged to sell their
flats and downsize one catch underlying
all of this is hidden in the definition
of ownership here that means 99-year
leases
for the most part residents are free to
buy sell and inherit property with a few
exceptions but the government is always
and only the true owner none have yet
expired but as that date steadily
approaches the question of what happens
next - looms large and could present a
heated political challenge in the
meantime there's a bright side to
government ownership it's responsible
for maintaining renovating and even
upgrading public apartments free of
charge of course no system is without
flaws there is always a concern that the
same heavy-handed policies which make
housing so effective will be taken for
granted by younger generations or worse
perceived as a form of social control
indeed from the very beginning Singapore
has designed flats with the explicit
intent of shaping society a mild example
is the arranging of different size units
next to each other to create cohesion
between income levels to room units next
to three room 3 next to 4 and so on
while one in three room or two and five
room mixing was said to create more
division than unity more radically to
prevent earlier racial tension created
by separate and disconnected communities
public housing follow strict ethnic
quotas as of 2016 its majority 74%
Chinese residents could occupy no more
than 84% of a neighborhood it's 13
percent of Malays could occupy at most
22 percent and is 12 percent of Indians
could occupy 12 percent once an
ethnicity has reached its quota no more
are allowed to buy a flat in that
neighborhood or block level in theory
this encourages a sense of unity and
ensures different groups have close
contact by going to the same schools and
shopping together controversially though
it also means as a
product buying or selling a flat maybe
easier or harder based on your ethnicity
finally subsidies heavily favored
married families with children so much
so that locals joke will you marry me
has been replaced by can we buy a house
together in truth housing policy was
always just as much a means of
modernizing some would say erasing the
culture of Singapore as it was about
giving people a place to live
supporters argue the People's Action
Party has maintained its seven decade
monopoly on power for obvious reasons by
all measures HDB policies have had a
monumental impact on Singapore and there
is perhaps no issue more personally
significant than where with who and how
well your family lives
Synnex in turn counters that it's no
coincidence the party which meticulously
designed Singapore receives the vast
majority of its votes to the extent that
demographics family structure and
geography determined voting preferences
one could say the People's Action Party
has a built-in advantage naturally this
raises questions about transferability
setting aside the environment which
enabled its housing to thrive like its
disproportionate number of smart
charismatic leaders and its world-class
transit system Singapore's public
housing is also inseparably linked to
its unique brand of authoritarianism
where else
after all what constituencies trust
their government to acquire nearly all
land and to exerts near total control
over where and how they live even in
other autocratic states with similarly
absolute powers to the HDB how could
those powers possibly be utilized for
the benefit of the people not merely
hijacked for political gain so while
there are certainly lessons to be
learned and indeed some of its
state-owned companies have been
contracted abroad it should be clear
that its public housing is more an idea
than a method that despite how tempting
it may be to selectively copy and paste
from what appears to be a model nation
doing so without the foundation of a
strong powerful technocratic state would
produce only a weak house soon to fall
while we're all stuck in our houses why
not make use of that boredom to learn
something new
Skillshare has thousands of creative
classes to help you feel more
accomplished fend off boredom and just
generally have fun I've been watching
Thomas Frank's class on how to build and
maintain habits which walks you through
the steps of tracking your progress
reviewing your week and finding apps
that work for you what's great about
Skillshare is that the classes are short
and digestible but really shockingly
well-made if you're going to learn a new
skill learn it from the very best the
best filmmakers the best designers
writers and animators Skillshare has it
all there's just the right amount of
structure and detail to truly help you
learn with enough fun to keep you
entertained start learning a new skill
today by joining with the link in the
description the first 1,000 people will
get two months of unlimited skill share
premium after that it's less than ten
bucks a month with an annual
subscription